- You're the first photographer
to capture the blonde.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
Are you normally red, or?
- So when I first came out as trans,
I had just left my husband,
so I shaved my head,
had a GI Jane moment.
So definitely coming out
and growing out my hair
during the beginning phase of my womanhood
was definitely a
challenge since that does,
define a lot of your femininity.
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you came out?
- Three years ago.
- [Interviewer] Only three years ago?
How old are you now?
- I am 30 years old.
- [Interviewer] 30.
And were you, did you know
that you had this
inclination as a younger man?
- I think that, like when
you're, to answer that,
I think when you're younger,
you kind of don't really
think future terms of gender.
You just think, you just feel
and do, you don't, like guys or girls.
You're just like, "Ew boys,
Ew girls," so I've definitely
always been feminine.
- [Interviewer] And you've had surgeries?
- I have only had a little
twitch on my lips in Chicago.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so
tell me about your childhood.
You grew up where?
- I grew up in Dallas, Texas,
New York and Los Angeles.
And I had a great childhood,
lots of love, support
so much love that, I,
at the end of the day
I truly think that there's more
good in the world than bad.
- [Interviewer] Sounds great.
And so you had both your parents?
- Yes, divorced, but still very equal.
Weekends in New York with my dad
and week with my mom in Dallas.
- [Interviewer] Were
there signs of this coming
when you were like a teenager?
- A little bit, I think
it's one of those things
where you try to express
something to someone,
but closed mouths don't get fed.
So I was trying to show my femininity,
et cetera, but I never said,
I never fully said it until
my divorce from my husband.
So that definitely made the
woman come out for sure, so.
- [Interviewer] And how did
your family react to that?
- They've kind of taken
it as, they don't really,
my family worries more
about me being a good person
and taking care of myself physically,
emotionally, psychologically.
I think what you choose to
do, in the world or bedroom,
you know, that kind of...
My parents, I can only speak for myself,
they just want to see me happy.
And mom and dad definitely
see through everything
so I try to, put on, a
happy face if you will,
but they definitely want me
to be a happy, healthy person.
- [Interviewer] That's great to hear.
So you've had relationships
with men before?
- Yes, I am a hetero trans woman.
I'm not own, and I don't, like I said,
judge to each their own.
I've never had,
(laughing)
I guess, a "transbian" experience.
That's a word I learned
from the community.
It's "trans" and the word lesbian
kind of morphed, which is transbian.
So I have a lot of close
girlfriends but I've never...
I mean I've kissed a girl, but...
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I was, I was gothic, preppy, theater,
all those into one big...
- [Interviewer] And then
you moved from Dallas to?
- Dallas to Orange County when I was 20,
then that's when I met my
ex-husband and we came to Dallas.
Then I left him and
moved back to California.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Got it, okay.
And, so you're living where,
are you living on Skid Row now?
That's where I met you.
- No, I literally did not
even know that was Skid Row.
I was in, near Melrose,
my friend invited me.
Met this guy online, in a
nutshell, he Ubered me to LA.
He Ubered me to Hollywood.
You never turn down Hollywood.
So I said, sure.
And his credit card "wasn't
working," quote-unquote.
And I've been here for 24 hours
and I just revealed my golden locks.
- [Interviewer] So where
are you staying tonight?
- At an undisclosed location.
- [Interviewer] You don't know yet?
- I don't.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
so you'll figure it out?
- Absolutely, always.
- [Interviewer] So you're
not homeless, you've always
had a place to stay?
You've always had a roof over your head?
- I always have had a roof over my head.
There've probably been, I would say,
four or five days where you
kinda got to keep it going.
And those days I don't
like to put that in my head
because when you put defeat
in your head, it doesn't,
the universe doesn't, for me,
I can only speak for myself.
And I have to excuse my
nails that are not done
during this apocalypse going
on, I just found a nail artist.
- [Interviewer] You had no
time to prepare for this.
- No time.
- [Interviewer] I plucked
you off the street.
(Demi laughing)
- Yeah, so definitely
It's throwing me back
I had a blond moment, what were we just,
what was I, where were we at there?
- [Interviewer] I can recall.
(Demi laughing)
- [Interviewer] But so
you're down here on Skid Row,
there's lots of drugs down here.
Are drugs a part of your life?
- There's something that, how do I answer
that question unfortunately.
But surprisingly that's
not why I'm here today.
- [Interviewer] Okay, I buy it.
What do you do for money?
- I, what do I do for money?
I was-
- [Interviewer] I've heard
everything, so nothing
you gonna tell me is going
to surprise me, nothing.
- In a nutshell, I grew up
with money, married into money,
made my own money.
I would say I'm an escort
but I'm terrible at being
seductive, et cetera.
Once you get to know me, that's I'm-
- [Interviewer] But you have
clientele that appreciate your-
- I don't, I just, I
grew into my looks and
I just, guys helped me out.
I asked, I can't put a
price to my sexuality
or to my time.
I just built relationships
and I'm like, "Hey, you know,
this is what's going on."
So, you know, to answer
that, I think we're all
in this world, pimps and hoes,
if you will, to some extent.
(Mark laughs)
- [Interviewer] And do
you get treated nicely
in your general life?
- Generally, generally, I've
always have felt personally...
And I'm just, it's probably
because of the day, et cetera.
I've always felt kind of like a trophy.
And in this world, you know, you have to,
one of my deans at KD
conservatory in Dallas Texas
said, Demi once you realize
your place in the pendulum,
or something, it was really,
I can't quote it exactly.
So that's, realizing that
I'm living in a world
and I have a certain look, skills, assets.
And just going with that as...
If that makes sense, in
a weird artistic way.
(laughs)
Sorry.
- [Interviewer] Sure, what
plans do you have for your life?
You're still young, where
do you see yourself?
- [Demi] I want to be a respected artist.
I want to be an accomplished artist.
I want to be a strong business woman.
I want to, I still
believe in love regardless
of my abusive marriage.
That would, the whole Orange County mom.
I saw this one lady, you
know, in her leggings,
jogging with her, she's literally
running with a stroller,
just pushing it and I was
like, and she had this, like,
blonde ponytail, I was like, wow.
That's, I mean, it's a beautiful
day, she's running and her,
you know, that's, you know,
so I would like to have
my own family, be healthy and happy, yeah.
My own sense of happiness.
- [Interviewer] And when you
say an artist, what is your-
- [Demi] I think that as artists, we...
I am not necessarily a painter,
photographer, et cetera.
I've dabbled, but I do have somewhat of
a formal education in
acting, drama, fine arts.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any issues like with
anxiety, or depression, or
anger, or stuff like that?
- [Demi] I do, part of me.
I do have anxiety.
I've seen the same therapist
for 15, or psychiatrist,
Dr. (indistinct), Uptown
(indistinct) family medicine.
Did, I haven't just, an ex...
Throwing in a side note.
An ex of mine said, have you
only seen that psychiatrist?
I said, no, I've had other
therapists. So don't...
But yeah, the only thing I do suffer from
is extreme social anxiety.
Debilitating, too.
That's kind of what kept
me from making friends,
if you will know so much of my feminism,
not so much the way I act, whatever.
I kind of have a tendency
to seclude myself
and I stick out so much
that I can't really be
with the group, which I'd like to.
- [Interviewer] But what is your fear?
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] What is your fear?
It's probably irrational,
but what is your fear?
- Probably someone hurting me.
Which has, the only person
that's ever physically hurt me
has been the guy I just married.
Which breaks my heart,
but made me stronger too.
But that's part of being
a woman, is heartbreak.
My voice teacher always
said, Demi, men see shit
and women don't, and to
take everything, life...
I'm a huge crier, which
sucks with my allergies
and makeup, et cetera.
To take everything, all the
feeling that life throws at you,
just is the hardest
thing about being a girl.
- [Interviewer] All right, Demi.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And very nice meeting you.
- Nice meeting you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.